what we're going to do in this video is
add 48 029 to 233
930 and like always pause this video and
i really encourage you to try to figure
it out on your own and let's see if we
get the same answer and if we don't why
all right so the way i'm going to tackle
this i assume that you've had a go at it
i'm going to take the larger number i'm
going to write it on top i'm really
doing the standard method there's
multiple ways where you can add multiple
multi-digit numbers but what i'm going
to do is really the most typical method
and i'm going to write the smaller
number below it but i'm going to match
up the place value so i'm going to write
the ones place in the same column as the
ones place on the top number so
this is the ten thousands place so 48
000 and 29 so nine is nine ones zero
ones two tens three tenths so on and so
forth and now i am ready to add
so let's start in the ones place
and if i'm adding numbers it's always a
good idea to start in the ones place
zero ones plus nine ones is nine ones
and then i can go into the tens place
three tens plus two tens is five tens
this is going well all right
then i go to the
hundreds place nine hundreds plus zero
hundreds well that's just going to be
nine hundreds so far so good
all right now something interesting is
going to happen in the thousands place
thousands plus eight thousands well that
would be eleven thousands but we can
rewrite eleven thousands as one thousand
and one ten thousand sometimes you might
see this described as carrying the one
three plus eight is eleven where you
carry the one but all you're really
doing is regrouping three plus three
thousand plus eight thousand is eleven
thousand we write the one thousand here
and then you write the ten thousand
right over there in the ten thousand
place
and now
so we have one ten thousand plus three
ten thousands plus four ten thousands so
one plus three plus four that's eight
ten thousands or eighty thousand
and then last but not least we have
these two hundred thousands right over
there and we're done two hundred eighty
one thousand nine hundred and fifty nine
did you get the same answer